hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Astro near I'm here
with Wolfie say hi hi now Wolfie I met
at pax about a year ago PAX Prime which
is now known in pax West right yeah yeah
and so we met through the the
make-a-wish program and we were gonna do
a collab here and don't ask me why it
took nine months because I was supposed
to I'm supposed to do this much sooner
hey we're both busy people here right
we're busy we gotta decide chop up our
days yeah so I'll get into the the what
why and what we're doing here as soon as
I can figure out how to freaking control
this because I can't get the music to go
down it's so dumb okay alright so I'm
gonna launch again oh whoops I didn't
launch I forgot that doesn't launch it
goes to a loading screen oops okay then
I'm gonna invite you to my game like
thusly invite the game did you get an
invite yes I did
alright no joy you I've you shipped in
tab yep never tell your password to
anyone tell me your password man I don't
know the password you don't have a
password you expect me to believe it
it's usually something very very like
you can't decipher it penis six
nine is that it it was that's really
close but it's actually nine six Oh
penis you almost hit the nail on
the head oh man this cuz I know yeah I
know yeah yeah yeah you knew what I was
thinking okay so anyway we're playing
Astra near again number one because
there's been a lot of updates to the
game and number two like I mentioned
Wolfie and I met through the make-a-wish
Foundation and if you wanted to talk
about you know what's going on in the
emeriti in the immediate future because
you have to go on dialysis very soon
don't you yeah I do
can I just launch and I'll meet you yeah
come on down I thought you were already
here which ones no I finally loaded back
up I'm gonna be big bobblehead astronaut
yeah I am I have a kidney what is it
called I have a kidney problem I guess
would be the best way to sum it up and
what happens
is that my membranes are clogged because
there's somewhat of 23 in each kidney
and oh wow that's load of bad and yeah
I'm landing yeah you're gonna play Oh
God
you don't know hi hello I was gonna be a
bobble head uh-huh yeah okay oh don't
point at me you get anything out but I
am recently my kidney function is
dropped - oh I got it I figured it out
it's eight to 12 percent and that was
roughly two weeks ago so it's probably
below that now and whether I want to or
not I don't really have a choice whether
to go on dialysis or not and then
hopefully in the near future I can get
glass cute you only get one though just
know that I tell everybody when they
sneeze you only get one oh thank you for
being so generous with those bless yous
I appreciate that very much welcome
anytime
all right so do you Nate you never
played this game before though right no
so much different than that no don't you
worry about a thing I'm an expert at
this so it's just you run don't don't
run hang on wait I forget how to I
forget out of not do something like that
I'm an expert how do I do this
oh okay wow that was that was weirdly
snake-like and girthy at me yeah in this
game you have to go and collect
resources and then build structures with
which to be able to build what you need
to build make sense sort of yeah okay so
on the ground with your terrain tool
like see this resin over here if you
mouse over it you can left click on it
and you'll start sucking it up into your
gun
just like that now you want to always
make sure that you suck a full stack out
of there because if you don't suck a
full stack if you start sucking
something else you'll lose what you were
stacking so you always got to make sure
you get a full stack of the thing that
you actually want not just goofin
you can also oh I got it there you go
you know what you're doing yeah you can
also get these plants here to get more
stuff you got plant materials and then
if you hit Q you'll go into your
backpack and then you can make certain
items like a solar panel is very nice
because that way you get more power so
you can suck more makes any compound for
everything exactly so we got to go out
and we got to get compound so you need
to wait you have will you I don't know I
I had some fine whatever I put resin
oh my head I knew it was gonna happen I
just didn't tell you because I knew
before you did dude stop acting
confident you don't know what's going on
and neither do i okay so that build
these that built something that is like
a standard template construct it can
build a printer it can build a smelter
it can build a vehicle BAE can build a
research station so the one thing that
we probably need to do first is the read
what are you doing alright so we need to
we need to get more compound but to do
that we need to have various other
things so actually let me see if I can
is there a way like I can trade with you
or something okay I'm dropping this
compound on the ground you see that
there I got it hit Q on the bottom flip
over until you see small solar hmm yes
you're gonna want it alive you're gonna
want to build that okay there you go so
now you got a solar panel on your
backpack which means that you're gonna
be able to get more help it's nighttime
is it though is it just look up is it
though yes is it I'm confident in that
much okay I know the Sun I've been
staring at it for a while okay good for
you that's not what you're supposed to
be doing but they are supposed to come
up dramatically at that point because I
think it's almost daytime but if you
come with me we're gonna go on an
expedition and there's gonna be
dangerous because we only have a certain
amount of oxygen if we run out of oxygen
we die make sense pretty much okay cool
glad we're on the same page here and OH
the Sun is about to come up how cool is
that it's so lucky that I found a solar
panel by myself yeah you did it all by
yourself you're such a good good good
ass well we should probably get back
okay so this was uh what what this is
here is this is a wreck
so the wrecks usually contain
researchable things there big old
bulbous things that you got to drag back
over to a research station don't you
build that yeah you better come back
we're about to run out of oxygen and die
that's no good yeah you should pay
attention pretty much that's what you
should definitely do yeah run oh I'm at
way lower oxygen than you I am
suffocating it's cuz you mean you're
renting you're supposed to be all kinds
of rationing here we go there we go and
no I'm not gonna give you my breath no
it's my breath I could have died good
then you would have learned a lesson all
right so the second lesson is we would
so the second lesson is there's
resources all over the place you need to
look for the rocky white ones that kind
of look like not the not the blue dildo
like ones you need the ones over here
that are rocks these are calm the rocks
ahead down on the ground
stop staring up at the stars you need to
actually understand the problems that
are down here on earth so go over to
that other guy and gather that one see
this one over here and they don't run
try not to run you can run if you want I
mean you got enough oxygen right here
but just to gather up as much compound
as you can because compound in the
beginning of the game is the most
important thing that you can possibly
have because it's used to build the
majority of the things that we're gonna
be using make sense make sense
and now the Sun's up the solar panels
gonna be working you see how that's
useful what are we gonna use compound
for though I literally just said the
thing that gets you the most build to
the build thing that's what I just said
did I not just say I understand now I'm
I'm suffocating all right I'm gonna
build a research station you bring back
that stuff and don't die that's the rule
number one oh don't give me that old
mmm-hmm can I break rule number one okay
I was suffocating why would you break
rule number one can we bring
yeah actually I was just about to get to
that if you would let me actually be me
and how smart I am you would have
realized how great I am so if you watch
this
I made what are called tethers now with
tethers we can extend our effective
range of oxygen you see these blue lines
yeah
you connect them out and these are like
little beacons of oxygen they will keep
us alive as we go out and explore and
then we can pick them up you oaky
astronaut thank you wait you were me me
no I'm your like a slim fit one why do
you think I keep running out of breath I
don't know cuz look at me I'm a big ol
book because you got so much muscle you
need to actually move it around it's
yeah I got you back okay so what I'm
heading for right now is in the distance
I see pillars of compound and these
pillars oh this is a lot of resin right
here you might want to gather up this
stuff because there's a lot of goodness
you got the resin okay you get that
razzle will need resin later but there
are oodles of compound over here that
I'm going for
and these things are gonna really really
get our screwed stuff Oh such glorious
suckage I'm getting there I'm not a
master yeah that's okay because over
here on the left you can see oh watch
out for the precipice there's a cave
over here and it is a big drop and I
don't know how you'd get back field just
be careful about it just be careful
about it Oh God oh jeez it just looks
like a big big puddle in the ground yeah
don't you drop in alright okay too many
items so over here you have too many
items oh all that resin okay well we can
do eventually we'll create storage stuff
but let me let me fill up on what I need
I'm gonna get the rest of this compound
then we'll make a trip back and then
we'll have a good amount of resources to
be able to do everything that we need to
do so give me one second I'm gonna try
to I think this sounds like a pretty
good plan I'm glad that you know I
didn't elect you but you chose to be the
leader yeah well I mean as the one who
is played with before and is obviously
the
better of us it's gonna be me don't bust
out inside
that's only that's a second episode
skill you you don't bust out on the
first episode into song you got a you
got a build into that it takes time to
practice yeah yeah far yeah yeah we did
England let me get one more stack of
resin and then I'm gonna okay alright so
I'm full up on stuff we're gonna leave
those tezur0 he's build more tethers
later but once we get back I'm gonna
show you how to build more storage
facilities so that we can be able to
build what we need to build and then
eventually we're gonna be able to build
a frickin vehicle make sense noise noise
I know it's noise why can I put this
stuff on the back of this story it's
just storage anything you see like that
is de storage so what I'm building here
is I'm building another bay and we're
gonna build a vehicle bay right here
make sense cool great but we need
aluminum for that I forgot about that
so what we need to do first is we need
to build a smelter to be able to build
copper ore so this is our smelter make
sense great storage first you have
swords you got to pay attention see
you're not paying attention see if you
go to cue you can drag something out of
your inventory into any of those red
little circles there make sense why'd
you drop it don't drop it I can't I got
it you got a click twice nobody told me
about this hey if I shoot everything is
a double click until proven otherwise
okay that's good skills for life that's
a life lesson that is a life lesson and
markiplier provides life's lessons 101
with markiplier life 101 with Mark 1
alright so we don't have much compound
but we got a lot of resin so we got to
go back and get more compound but I
don't think there was any more on the
way over there but what we can do is we
can go into the cave yeah are you ready
to go into the cave let's do this the
answer is no you're not ready to go into
the cave because you have no idea how to
survive so I'm gonna show you how to go
into a goddamn cave okay so come with me
I hope adult yeah you here's the scary
thing you are an adult oh goodness I
know right
oh gosh Tara
fine nobody told me well you're not
quite an adult how old are you I'm
actually 19 yeah you're an adult that's
not you were an adult so yeah so you
suck you up and you come with me in this
cave make sense all right that sounds
good so here's where the dangerous thing
is see this this hole here you're gonna
have to jump in there okay jump in there
with you
but before I do that I must set up the
tethers which you should have done
because remember I was telling you about
the tethers how important they were
oh that's showing like you died how'd
you just die I jumped in a hole what and
then how'd you die I don't know I just
kind of laid there fell asleep and I
guess I don't know quick but you didn't
did you jump in
no I didn't jump in because I'm not an
idiot why I thought you jumped in and
didn't die and that's why you were like
why why did you die I still don't know
how did you what killed you Oh what
really oh man I didn't know you could
take fall damage I have no idea no idea
why would I have an idea it was like oh
no we're on a moon type thing you can
land well no apparently not the gate so
help me excavate the ground because what
I'm trying to do here is I'm trying to
create like a level path for us to get
down there you know what I mean it's
literally like nothing below us it's
just an entire cavern no no there's a
wall there's a wall where I'm digging
just stick here
yeah dig where I'm digging just keep
making a trough mmm nice donek that's
where the compound reservoir was it's
nothing right now hey dig yeah I told
you to dig you're a DD me dig there you
go that's helpful yeah there you go
I still die bro nah I'll be the test
well okay all right let me put some
tethers down oh I slid in tell me this
me out
you better wake me alive
almost fell yeah you better dig me out
here I mean I got tethers so I'm fine
whew this case on Oh this cave is
horrifying
oh good there's power down here so
that's good okay why don't you just come
on down well they're your Oh
thinks I was sucking you weren't you're
sucking then who was sucking all right
we'll get it later there's more power
here I'm just gonna dig out the crevice
here this is something this is something
Oh the yellow stuff that's power so it's
basically like portable power you you
suck it up and it's an item work it's
like a battery stop it's the future stop
questioning everything all right
hydrazine hydrazine that is a flammable
gas used for rocket fuel make sense I
got a big I got a big ol that's a
researchable now I'm going to grab on a
scavenge from your corpse and I'm going
to get your yeah it should I mean
I'm horrified to see your live faith all
right so I'm gonna keep building tethers
out into this cave because there's a lot
of goodies scoop up the power when you
can but don't fill your inventory
because we got a lot more I'm leaving
what are you leaving I gotta do research
I gotta be more smarter well okay you go
research I'll be down in this cave if
you hear screaming that means I'm dying
okay don't come for me though awesome
one cold cold you think I'm gonna come
for you I mean I'm just saying
I'll just call someone else then they
can deal with and then I'll be like
who's he live
was he alive I like how they used was
they didn't they don't even say is he
alive nah was he what was he my god I
dropped it
oh wow great job there if I'm using
telekinesis it's my first time oh the
sun's so creative yeah well it's dark
down here so maybe you could come help
this cavern is flipping huge not so
bright this cavern I like it anyone or
this okay I got in the research thing
okay yeah then activate the research
thing and then continue down with me I'm
out of I gotta build more tethers here
man I'm building a lot of tethers I
can't yet I think we need like power or
something we need power what do you mean
we need power it's not working you're a
liar you're a goddamn liar is what you
are whoa hey okay I'm deep in the I'm
video oh my god maybe I can build a
solar panel
I need cop-out yeah see you need
compound so get in this goddamn cave no
no I got some here I don't need to make
the work I got it how do you have some
ID I stole you stole worried we don't
have to get back you goddamn all
right so now I have to should I use it
to power or power me I don't know I
don't know what you're talking about
you've already got one so you might as
well put it on the the the base itself
it's doing something yeah a lot of
things on this planet do something I was
right
I'm bringing another research thing back
and then I I'm gonna try to find
compound elsewhere because obviously
research is my game
we're in this together me excuse me
mr. Wolfman this is a co-op game and
worried this together you got me there
yeah I got you there so why don't you
yeah see I've got a more interesting
research here I'll cover you
this is you said it's a shooter game
right that's what it was I didn't say
that at all
June stop I can't jump but I'm holding
this you
I can't get out well there we go
I got oh yeah shoot your son no no no
horrible I didn't know that would happen
oh yeah you didn't know at all yeah you
don't know how this game works I better
run while I can oh good yeah we don't
have
resin resins whoa why did you put you
put the research thing on the smeltery
to power on the smelter on the shelter
you didn't put it in the research
station you put it on the smelter wait
you that's how you learn you waft uh-huh
okay well while you were wafting I
actually did real research and we've got
a medium winter yeah that's from mine
and now I'm gonna claim your
researchable because you couldn't figure
out how to put it in the gosh-darn
research thing it's got this isn't even
a researchable this isn't this is just a
beach ball research you big goof a big
ol Marvel dude a big ol marble well I'm
gonna go over here come with me we're
gonna go over to the the derelict ship
here and we're gonna see if there's
anything of use over there and then we
got to go find compound because if we
don't find compound I'm going to
strangle you like see try look at my
speed yeah I don't think I can strangle
your giant bulbous head there
bobblehead okay how do you make tethers
what it's its compound again exactly as
I've been saying so excavate this
sumbitch here
just keep excavating dig it all out cuz
there's somebody colorable I know right
but get the goodies get all the goodies
also you can get materials from plant
life you can get organic stuff and
that'll eventually be useful for
something I have no idea what though
make sense cool keep digging
you need what I needed to breathe I was
suffocating
breathing's for the week I like do you
breathe are you saying you breathe more
than the average person here that you
got it well then you're not very fit for
space are you yeah I don't suck up
materials like you guys
suck up air yeah okay well under weekly
ah I think I've noticed this ah I found
the materials inside we've got titanium
nice okay we've got aluminum double nice
and organic materials there's other
stuff in there too but I can't quite get
to it jump in that hole that's not right
you didn't jump in the hole I jumped
away from now can't get it we got to go
in from like the bottom which means that
we gotta excavate it even more yes Oh
God
well let follow me what here I found the
ass end of it I'll try to go in this oh
I might be stuck in a hole I know I
might we start gonna hold though yeah
let me see if I can jump in this thing
ah Frick okay I'm good
that's the important part okay I made it
in yeah that's the important part
okay I've got a big it looks like the
chair to a vehicle here Oh God
so once we build a vehicle I've got a
delightful chair you won't see my chair
I don't know your own stupidity is that
what your stuff yeah a collab with the
old Mark II movie you get roasted pretty
much all over yeah whoa did you know
that you are I don't want to carry you
back you find your own way back what I
gonna carry you're broke don't sit in it
you Oh God good job you did it okay so
anyway that's all the time we got for
this episode here we're gonna pick this
up in another episode very soon so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
us know how we're doing the comments
below check out wolfies channel through
the link in the description in anything
you would like to say before the end
great thanks everybody and as always we
know go ahead know I was like yeah
that's good good cool it's mumbled great
and as always we will see you in the
next room
[Music]